- Earlier this year,
I met physics professor,
dr. David Wright.
I love him.
He had become a viral sensation
for his crazy cool classroom
experiments. Here he is
teaching me and my panel.
Newton's first law of motion.
- It's called the law of inertia.
- Okay.
- When you see people take a table cloth
and pull out it underneath the dishes?
It's like a magic trick.
- Magic.
- But its not magic
- (Crowding cheering )its physics.
- physics
- I thought inertia was
something I could catch.
- (Laughing)
- Sounds like an STD.
- (crowd and every one laughing)
- I know
- I had it once
I had it once.
- so Here's a cream. You're fine.
- So the law of inertia
says that objects at rest
stay
at rest
unless they're acted upon
by some outside force.
- Okay.
- In this case,
the outside force is the tablecloth.
- Okay.
- But it's fairly smooth.
So the force is small.
And if
you pull it quickly,
you must pull it quickly because
then you have a small force
for a short period of time and it,
it works.
- okay
- So here's the trick.
- You got to take this tablecloth
and don't take your palms down.
Otherwise you might pull it like this.
- Okay
- That will not work
so get your palms down one at a time.
Now get skilled practice,
but don't pull it yet.
- Okay. Okay.
- Alright. Get step back far enough.
so you pull your hands back like this
- Ooh you have room
- Poof
- Yeah
- Got it.
- Stay back
- (crowd cheering)
- Ooh my god
- ( cheering) ooh my god
all right so you know,
I love some fun experiments.
So I asked professor Wright.
If he'd zoom in so we can
test out some more theories.
Y'all ready. All right.
Hello.
- Oh, good to see you
- Its so good to see you
as well professor Wright.
Thank you so much for joining us again.
- It's a pleasure to be here
its exciting to be on
physics
on TV.
- Yes It is. I love your
yellow wall, by the way.
I love anything yellow
- Ooh thank you ,thank you
- sunflowers.
- Thank you.
- So you you have a new
experiment for me right?.
what theory we testing.
- We testing buoyancy today
will see how things sink,
see how things float
now the problem is
a hundred thousand ton
aircraft carrier float,
a penny sinks
its not about the weight.
it's about something called density.
The density is the mass
divided by the volume.
So for example this is a gram
big piece and a little piece
this one has eight times the mass
and this one weighs eight times as much
also has eight times the
volume has the same density
- Okay.
- Density is all about the
stuff things are made out of
- Hm
- Things are made of , things
that are more dense in water
are gonna sink
things that are less dense in water
like this gum ball here
are gonna float
and rocks gonna sink in
fact they sink like a rock.
(Laughing) Hahaha
- (Laughing) Hahahaha
- So your task I'm gonna
give you six different items
to guess will they sink
or will they float.
Are they more dense in water
or are they less dense in water.
- Okay.
- Keep in mind is this,
this is not easy
a lot of physicist will
get some of these wrong
so if you mess waters to you .
- I' am fine with looking
stupid Dr Wright so your good.
(Laughing).
- All right we start with a tomato
- A tomato
- Will it sink or will it float
- I feel like a tomato is going to sink
- Are you ready?.
One ,two ,three
- Ooh it did. Ooh shot
- Ooh no, it came back up
- Ooh shot.
- All right.
Now what about a diet soda
- Wait is the can closed
and the soda still in it.
- still in it
go on a diet soda
- I'm gonna say ,I'm
gonna say it will float
cause iv been at the lake
and iv seen things float.
- Yes it did.
- Both cheering
- There you go
- Now he is the trick.
Here's that sugar soda
and the sugar soda sinks
to the bottom
- Ooh that's so bad
- All that sugar dissolved in it
and so even though
the can the same size and
is twelve fluid ounces
in both hands
its got like forty grams of sugar
dissolved in it so it sinks.
- Ooh Wow.
- You've done pretty good so far.
- That should tell us something
about wen we are drinking it shouldn't it.
(laughing).
- Now, you ever did bopping for apples
- Yes this is gonna totally float
- Ooh fair enough
- Ooh yeh.
- Yes
I was like iv been to an
October festival thing
- Now this is a naval orange
that has been peeled
is it gonna sink or is it gonna float?.
- Ah I'm gonna say its gonna
sink because all the the water
is gonna go into it right
and its gonna be heavier
- All right so lets see,
and it does indeed sink to the bottom
youve done really well I'm excited.
- Ooh wait if you would
have kept the peel on
would it have floated.
- Aah I just happen to have
one with the peel on and
- I was going to say that
gonna float isn't it.
Aah interesting.
- Coz the peel is like a life jacket
- Aah
- You take a piece of the
peel and the peel floats
a lot of air mixed in
so its not dense at all
so by putting them in pieces
you know personal flotation
device to the orange
- Yeah Wow.
does it mean science so cool.
i love this.
Well thank you so much Professor Wright.